mer des caraïbes l'île necker une
résidence de rêve 30 hectares de jungle
et de sable fin où vit un incroyable
randin sont des affaires
oui c'est mon bureau ici j'ai beaucoup
de chance j'ai toujours travaillé à la
maison
de temps en temps je dois aller à droite
à gauche
c'est tellement mieux ici l'heureux
propriétaire de sept îles c'est richard
branson
un homme parti de rien qui pèse
aujourd'hui près de 3 milliards d'euros
une des plus grosses fortunes
britanniques il a même été anobli par la
reine d'angleterre
c'est le sommet du monde à 56 ans le
fondateur de virgin affiche son succès
sans complexe et virgin megastore au
transport aérien
en passant par les trains la téléphonie
mobile et même le tourisme spatial
richard branson a bâti un incroyable en
pays représente dans une trentaine de
pays
et pourtant au départ cet homme à qui
tout semble réussir était un gamin à
problèmes un attardé qu'on disait sans
amour
[Musique]
le petit richard branson est né en 1950
il a grandi à la campagne dans cette
maison près de bournemouth dans le sud
de l'angleterre
il est issu d'une famille bourgeoise
papa est avocat maman est hôtesse de
l'air mais les deux parents sont
désespérés par leur fils aîné richard
est dyslexique et à 8 ans il ne sait
toujours ni lire ni écrire
la rigueur de l'enseignement et les
coups de bâton n'y change rien c'est un
cancre moqué dans les cours d'école nous
sommes à londres chez johnny james
aujourd'hui scénariste du réalisateur
tim burton
il était le seul ami de brandson à
l'école et quarante ans après il se
souvient très bien de ce garçon timide
pas plus doué en sport comme
mathématiques il avait deux ans de
retard à l'école tout le monde le
prenait pour un débile ni un idiot peu
creuse icône ans parce qu'il était
vraiment nul en cours et il était
vraiment différent de tous les autres
élèves d'efront
le jeune richard se sentent exclus très
tôt il sait qu'il devra se battre pour
s'en sortir il va alors se forger un
caractère de gagneur dans ses archives
johnny james en a gardé un témoignage ça
c'est drôle
regardez poésie et j'ai quoi de l'école
et je crois qu'il ya un peu une triche a
ici branson a 12 ans quand il écrit ces
lignes le titre en dit long ambition
woking corridos vous avez trouvé ça
johnny jay sacré à dakar que j'étais un
petit garçon très précoce et je sentais
malgré mon jeune âge que je pouvais
changer le monde j'avais le sentiment
d'avoir une responsabilité celle de
faire la différence pour faire la
différence
richard branson abandonne le collège il
n'a que 15 ans il n'a qu'une idée en
tête prendre sa revanche faire parler de
lui nous sommes en 1968 la jeunesse et
contestataire avide de liberté de
nouveautés
richard branson lance alors student le
premier magazine étudiant dans lequel on
aborde tous les sujets sans tabou ça
c'est le premier numéro
cheikh guèye ça parle de ségrégation
d'histoire politique
mai 68 en france regardez on y parle
aussi de drogue de sexe
et ça marche ces soins de feu sont ce
numéro le tout premier ça a été un
énorme succès c'était incroyable on en a
vendu 50 mille exemplaires c'était
énorme
tout le monde disait mais c'est
hallucinant comment vous avez fait vous
êtes des gosses
j'avais 15 ans richard on en avait 16
pour monter son journal branson a
commencé par emprunter cette cave à la
mère d'un copain mais il lui faut aussi
trouver de l'argent
il va y aller à l'esbrouffe et va vendre
des pages de pub avant même la sortie du
premier numéro
ses atouts c'est son culot et sa voix
même si richard n'avait que 16 ans il
avait une très grosse voix vous voyez en
f1 et au téléphone on aurait cru qu'il
en avait trop du coup ils faisaient
toutes ses affaires au téléphone
j'appelais coca cola pour tenter de les
persuader d'acheter de la pub dans notre
magazine et ça marchait pas alors j'ai
une idée j'ai rappelé ont disons que
pepsi était intéressé pour prendre une
page et là ça a marché
très tôt j'ai compris que les gens
réagissent à la compétition
reste un problème de taille pour le
jeune patron il ne peut pas payer les
journalistes richard branson va alors
avoir une idée plutôt originale pour
recruter de la main d'oeuvre gratuite
l'idée était de ramener des filles
on savait que si on arrivait à attirer
des jolies filles les garçons viendrait
avec et on pourrait être oui tous les
faire travailler les soirs estudante
deviennent vite très couru il faut dire
qu'elles sont plutôt libéré la santé du
journal s'en ressent les recettes
publicitaires sont aussi irrégulière que
les parutions
trois ans après sa création branson
laisse tomber le journal car il a déjà
un nouveau projet
les jeunes anglais ne jure plus que par
jimi hendrix les rolling stones et les
beatles
alors la nouvelle idée du jeune
ambitieux c'est de leur vendre des
disques mais toujours sans un sou il
faut encore ruser pour trouver des
locaux
c'est dans cette église que démarre la
saga virgin
c'est ici que tout a commencé
virgin a véritablement démarré dans
cette église à l'intérieur mais en
dessous en 2006 p il y avait cette
grande crypte puantes plein de tombes
mais vous êtes les chrétiens ouais bien
sûr on s'est tous fait baptiser ici
comme ça il ne laissait utiliser la
crypte pour stocker nos disques et donc
ça c'est l'entrée de la kryte et comme
vous pouvez le constater ces très étroit
selon la légende c'est dans cette crypte
que le nom virgin aurait été inventé
dans les vapeurs de haschisch
mais en réalité branson a récupéré le
nom d'une société en faillite
virgin la vierge en anglais d'où cette
égérie sur le premier logo de l'anah
[Musique]
il commence par vendre des disques par
correspondance et très vite il ouvre son
propre magasin ce sera l'ancêtre des
virgin megastore bronson prend des
crédits multiplie les boutiques et
introduit des innovations
révolutionnaires comme les premiers
écouteurs en libre accès le succès est
tel que ces magasins se transforme en
squat disque écouteurs platine sont
régulièrement voler branson est débordée
et les dettes s'accumulent
à 21 ans il doit un million et demi
d'euros la banque sa folle mais lui
garde la tête froide
il a déjà une nouvelle idée pour bluffer
son banquier le directeur de la mangue
est arrivé et a dit richard vous allez
avoir de gros problèmes
on va saisir la maison de vos parents on
va tous vous prendre même vos chaussures
vous devez nous rendre l'argent que vous
avez emprunté et richard connaissait la
loi il a dit vous ne pouvez pas faire ça
je ne peux pas vous payer un million de
livres je ne peux même pas vous donner
20 livres le banquier lui a demandé ce
qu'ils comptaient faire et richard a
répondu une maison de disques
je sais qu'on va y arriver avec une
maison disque la banque lui à leur
prêter de l'argent pour le label virgin
rickers le tout premier pari du nouveau
label virgin est un authentique ou de
chance il s'appelle michael j un
débutant alors refusé par toutes les
grandes maisons dit sa musique à base de
synthétiseurs est expérimental
ces quelques notes vont changer la vie
de richard branson
c'est simone rappeur un cousin de
richard branson qui a repéré le jeune
compositeur
à l'époque il n'imagine pas une seconde
l'immense succès qui les attendent
[Musique]
on n'avait aucune expérience dans le
business avec de l'enregistrement
musical
on n'avait aucune idée de ce qu un gros
succès voulait dire on espérait faire un
bon score en sortant cinquante ou cent
mille albums et au final on en a vendu
des millions
[Musique]
l'album tu vu la rebelle se prend la
tête du hit parade dès sa sortie et les
ventes sont colossales
avec 13 millions de disques écoulés
c'est toujours aujourd'hui le onzième
album le plus vendu de l'histoire du
royaume uni
virgin records rembourser toutes ses
dettes en six mois le pari mike oldfield
et un jackpot
richard branson devient millionnaire il
n'a que 23 ans fait son match mais les
profits qu'on a fait on était très vite
dépensés dans des groupes qui étaient
beaucoup moins talentueux le problème
quand on a du succès avec son premier
album c'est qu'on croit que c'est facile
à utiliser mais en fait on a vite
compris qu'on avait eu un coup de chance
et que les choses ne seraient pas si
simple à bronson a beau courtiser les
meilleurs artistes du moment comme mick
jagger
il n'arrive pas à accrocher un groupe à
succès jusqu'en 1977
ah tiens
la vague punk déferle sur l'angleterre
est un groupe fait plus de bruit que les
autres l'aient sex pistols
il joue très vite et très fort vocifère
des torrents d'insultés incite à
l'émeute la jeunesse anglaise en
raffolent mais le show business mais
rejette pour cent mille euros
autant dire une bagatelle richard
branson signent leur premier album never
mind the bollocks littéralement on s'en
bat les couilles
la raison pour laquelle il a voulu
signer les sex pistols sinon c'est parce
qu'ils avaient dit acculés à la
télévision c'est parce qu'il s'était
fait jeter de leur maison de disques
richard adoré ce genre de publicité et
puis quand l'album never mind the
bollocks est sorti on a été poursuivi
pour propos insultants c'est richard
adoré la publicité que nous faisait les
tribunaux le plus célèbre de ces coups
de pub ce sera le jour de l'anniversaire
de la reine
[Applaudissements]
depuis une péniche sous les balcons de
westminster les sex pistols streit la
reine de criminels et de fasciste
le groupe est arrêté par la police le
sourire du chanteur johnny rotten fait
le tour du monde
le disque de vie est un succès
international virgin entre dans la cour
des grands labels il faut prendre des
risques dans la visent les sex pistols
ont changé virgin
ils nous ont installé sur la scène
internationale c'est un risque mais un
risque calculé et prendre des risques
branson adore ça nous sommes en 1984 et
à 34 ans il vit sur une péniche dirige
la cinquième maison disque du monde et
emploie 4000 personnes mais il a soif de
défis et surprend tout son monde en
dévoilant son nouveau projet une
compagnie aérienne je pensais que lancer
une compagnie aérienne était une idée
complètement folle parce que ça n'avait
aucun rapport avec ce qu'on faisait
alors que ça marchait bien aux as et ça
pouvait nous faire perdre beaucoup
d'argent
richard tu détestes que les gens lui
disent non ne fait pas ça sinon il va
faire le maximum pour vous prouver que
lui il peut le faire le pari de branson
est fou tous ses collaborateurs crois
qu'il a perdu les pédales
il veut concurrencer le géant british
airways avec des vols à prix cassé sa
première ligne londres new york est
inaugurée en grande pompe au printemps
1984 virgin atlantic d'école avec un
seul avion
branson a loué l'appareil il a dû aller
négocier personnellement avec les
patrons de boeing pour arracher la faire
je suis allé faire un deal avec going on
ne leur a pris qu'un seul boeing 747
d'occasions nous avions convenu que si
ça ne marchait pas on le leur rendrait
un nom plus tard on assurer nos arrières
et on a dit on y va y avait des gars
mais avec un seul appareil et une seule
ligne
les débuts de virgin atlantic sont
difficiles d'autant que richard branson
n'a pas les budgets publicitaires de ses
concurrents alors pour attirer
l'attention du public
le patron de virgin va payer de sa
personne son nouveau cheval de bataille
tenté d exploit en ballon juillet 1987
virgin a fait construire le plus grand
ballon du monde bronson veut être le
premier à traverser l'atlantique en
montgolfière un volet pic à plus de 10
mille mètres d'altitude dans une capsule
pressurisée
c'est une première trente cinq heures
plus tard
crash en mer d'irlande l'équipage est
sauvé in extremis de la noyade par la
royal navy ronson et son coéquipier peur
lindstrand deviennent des héros le coup
tu pour virgin atlantic est énorme
après notre traversée de l'atlantique
les retombées publicitaires ont été
évalués à près de 20 millions d'euros au
second point ce tout petit
investissement départ richard est le
premier à réaliser le potentiel des
voyages en ballon pour la publicité
landes avant la couverture médiatique
n'était que local il a transformé sa en
événements internationaux
c'est sa grande force il voit le
potentiel c'est un visionnaire
résultat virgin atlantic profite à plein
de cette nouvelle notoriété
les avions se remplissent la touche
virgin fait parler d'elle tarifs 30 %
moins cher massage manucure et la star
richard branson en personne qui joue les
hôtesses de l'air pour épater la
clientèle
4 6 puis 8 avions la flotte s'étoffe
rapidement
sûr de lui branson fait le malin
déguisés en pirates et défient
publiquement british airways
il veut lui prendre le tiers de ses
clients british airways prend peur
[Musique]
avec plus de 200 appareils la compagnie
nationale est un mastodonte comparé à
virgin mais son pdg
le très guindé lors king est furieux de
se faire souffler ses passagers et même
le trophée de la meilleure compagnie
aérienne de l'année en 1981 le lord
anglais décident alors secrètement de
tout tenter pour couler virgin atlantic
c'est le début d'une guerre souterraine
lancé par british airways contre virgin
la presse l'appellera la campagne des
dirty tricks la campagne des coups bas
détective privé piratage informatique
filature british airways va employer des
méthodes d'espionnage pour salies
richard branson est déstabilisé virgin
atlantic le cerveau de cette opération
c'est un certain brian basham conseiller
de l'or qui quinze ans après les faits
il accepte de revenir sur cette histoire
avec quelques précautions
[Musique]
ma collègue est temps de prendre des
notes et pourquoi avoir une trace de ce
qui s'est passé
vous voulez être sûr de quoi mais pour
être sûr de votre lettre t elle prend
des notes
parce qu'on ne sait jamais vu vous avez
l'air très sympathique mais je vais être
sûr de votre honnêteté j'ai rencontré
beaucoup trop de gens malhonnêtes de ma
vie
sa mission était simple enquêté pour le
compte de british airways sur la face
cachée de richard branson
mon job à british airways était de dire
à tout le monde ce que j'avais découvert
sur grandson et comme je mener une
enquête financière sur ses affaires il
était vital de savoir d'où venait son
cash et le cash venait d'une boîte de
nuit
appelez le funk le haven c'est ce night
club londonien une boîte de nuit gay
dont branson est propriétaire depuis dix
ans la réputation de la boîte et
sulfureuse basham va tenter de
l'exploiter pour répandre des rumeurs
dans la presse
il entre en contact avec un journaliste
christophe shins alors reporter pour le
journal à scandales today voici sa
version des faits planète le plan dans
lequel bachem voulais m'impliquer
c'était de faire sortir une affaire dans
la presse
selon lui richard branson le pdg de
virgin était propriétaire d'une boîte de
nuit qui vendait de la drogue
autrement dit richard branson était
impliqué dans un trafic de drogue
ici ça que british airways voulait et ce
alors unis car toute l'image de virgin
dépend des de l'image de richard branson
nos journalistes contacte alors richard
branson pour vérifier certaines
informations
convaincu de sa bonne foi il la forme de
l' enquête que mène british airways
branson va alors lui demander un service
très particulier
bronson n'a pas arrêté de m'appeler ce
week end là sans arrêt et finalement il
m'a dit tu es tu prêt à les revoir ce
type et à l'enregistrer vous savez avec
un micro caché il voulait avoir une
preuve de cette conversation il voulait
avoir la trace de ce que cet homme
raconter sur lui au nom de british
airways
le journaliste pense tenir à ce coup il
finit par accepter la proposition de
brandson j'ai tout enregistré que
j'avais ce magnétophone dans la poche
j'étais très nerveuse parce que quand je
suis arrivé basham avait un fusil dans
les mains pardon il était en train
d'astiquer un fusil de chasse
j'étais très intimidée et je pense que
c'est ça qui voulait il voulait
m'impressionner pendant une heure au
domicile de bryant asham
le journaliste va discrètement
enregistré toute sa conversation avec
l'homme des british airways
on y parle de brandson du even de drogue
qu'on soit bien sûr j'ai été piégé
enfin piégée j'ai été déçu par un
journaliste de toute petite envergure et
par un homme extrêmement immoral avec
cette cassette
le patron de virgin tient enfin une
preuve tangible des manoeuvres de
british airways contre lui et bronson le
fait savoir
le scandale sort dans la presse quelques
jours plus tard
virgin attaque british airways en
diffamation devant la haute cour de
justice de londres
british airways voulait le traîner dans
la boue et c'est finalement richard
branson qui triomphe virgin enfonce
british hawaii ce titre le sun
l'ex-compagnie nationale doit s'excuser
et verser la somme record de 610000
livres de dommages et intérêts lors king
doit démissionner bronson est plus
populaire que jamais david a vaincu
goliath
si je n'avais pas réussi à convaincre ce
journaliste de m'aider l'entreprise
aurait pu disparaître
on se battait pour notre peau on se
battait pour la survie de la compagnie
et des 5000 personnes qui travaillaient
pour virgin
branson a gagné la bataille de l'opinion
mais la campagne des coups bas a coûté
cher frais de justice baisse d'activité
en 1992 branson est endetté c'est
contraint et forcé qu'il se sépare de
virgin music la maison de disque qui l'a
rendu riche
le joyau de la couronne est vendue au
label ea émail pour un milliard de
dollars
il arme ans quand j'ai vu les titres des
journaux qui annonçait branson virgin
pour un milliard de dollars
j'ai pleuré ce n'était pas une chose
facile à faire mais bon pour la première
fois de ma vie j'avais de l'argent
devant moi on était prêt à donner une
nouvelle mission à virgin on allait
pouvoir installer virgin dans d'autres
secteurs économiques partout dans le
monde au milieu des années 90 virgin
transporte un million et demi de
passagers
british airways doit désormais compter
avec le jeune patron star
ouais
en dix ans l'empiré virgin est devenu un
kaléidoscope de 350 sociétés très
hétéroclite
virgin c'est de la vodka
c'est aussi la première compagnie de
chemin de fer d'angleterre 300 megastore
à travers le monde
des bancs et même des robes de mariée
ronson épate la galerie mais ce n'est
souvent que poudre aux yeux
beaucoup de ces affaires perdre de
l'argent exemple virgin cola 1998
branson déclare la guerre à coca cola
sur ses terres et débarque à new york en
char d'assaut provocateur il écrase des
centaines de canettes de coca cola mais
trois ans plus tard
virgin cola s'avère être un flop les
pertes s'élèvent à 45 millions d'euros
[Musique]
selon tom bower un journaliste
britannique qui a enquêté plusieurs
années sur virgin le milliardaire est
avant tout un joueur de poker qui s'est
caché son jeu et se drogue
c'est un jongleur s'écrire autrement dit
il a toujours lancé un très grand nombre
d'affaires en même temps et son but
c'est qu'au final il y en ait au moins
une ou deux qui lui permettent de
toucher le jackpot
très peu de business vont lui rapporter
un maximum d'argent
les autres font faillite et il s'en fout
faire le dernier coup de richard branson
est l'un des plus spectaculaires 2001 il
a lancé en angleterre virgin mobile avec
un système d'abonnement basées sur les
cartes prépayées virgin opérateurs de
téléphonie débarque en france
avril 2006 nous sommes à paris au virgin
megastore des champs-elysées nous
retrouvons richard branson au sixième
étage du magasin sans costume ni cravate
comme à son habitude il s'apprête à
lancer en france sa marque de téléphonie
mobile avec une recette dont il a le
secret se donner en spectacle le show a
été annoncée dans la presse mais
personne ne connaît en détail la
nouvelle folie du milliardaire leurs
proches ou dessus il va jouer au
cascadeur
trente mètres plus bas fan journalistes
et badauds se pressent pour apercevoir
la star du business à 56 ans richard
branson n'hésitent pas à faire le pantin
suspendue à une corne
comme toujours brandson fait du business
en s'amusant
virgin se veut une marque jeune et
surtout une marque sexy alors il faut
que ça se voit
on en oublierait presque tout ce remue
ménage c'est d'abord pour faire des
affaires
le reste de sa journée consacrée à la
tournée des radios et télévisions
parisienne nous faisons une partie du
chemin avec lui mais il faut être en
première page pas sur la dernière c'est
le seul moyen si vous voulez que votre
société survivent
j'ai toujours utilisé ma personne pour
mettre virgin en avant et faire savoir à
tout le monde que virgin et xi'an access
le lendemain matin
branson fait la une de la presse
économique une nouvelle fois il a réussi
son coup mais l'opération n'est pas tout
à fait terminé il est 8 heures gare du
nord
le milliardaire par déjà vers l'eau on a
changé notre programme parce qu'on doit
annoncer un très gros deals en
angleterre en fait branson va tout
simplement échanger virgin mobile contre
10% d'un groupe de télévision
britannique
moins de 24 heures après son lancement
en france
sa compagnie de téléphonie mobile est
déjà revendu en angleterre un tour de
passe passe qui tient à en croire le
milliardaire dans cette petite pochette
là dedans il y à l'accord que je vais
signer cet après midi c'est un des plus
gros coups qu'on n'ait jamais fait
on a démarré virgin mobile il ya cinq
ans aujourd'hui ça vaut 2 milliards de
dollars alors qu'on était parti de rien
et maintenant on va utiliser cet argent
pour investir sur le marché de la
télévision hier on s'est installé sur le
marché français aujourd'hui on lance une
chaîne de télévision en angleterre c'est
une bonne journée
dans quelques mois le nouveau bébé de
richard branson sera une chaîne de
télévision qui portera le nom de virgin
bonne journée au passage richard branson
va personnellement empocher 180 millions
d'euros sur richard branson est
aujourd'hui l'entrepreneur le plus
populaire du royaume uni c'est aussi la
deuxième fortune du pays
des milliards dont il n'arrive jamais à
se contenter retour sur l'île necker
nani sa propre villa à 45 millions
d'euros est une petite entreprise
probablement la plus surprenante de
lempire virgili il tient absolument à
nous montrer ce film bronson est aussi
hôteliers des stars beaucoup de gens
très célèbres sont venus sur l'île
necker
steven spielberg warren beatty bill
gates presque toutes les stars sont
venus passer quelques jours ici c'est
complet 12 mois sur 12
et combien ça coûte de passer une
semaine ici et c'est pas ça c'est
environ 1500 dollars par jour et par
personne
nourriture et boissons comprises c'est
pas trop cher laissez pas très bon
marché non plus
[Musique]
si l'homme se donne à voir sans mystère
devant les caméras c'est qu'on te reste
une énigme
virgin est une multinationale qui
emploie plus de 35000 personnes dans le
monde
fait rarissime le groupe n'est pas coté
en bourse
[Musique]